[Music]  I'm patton oswalt and it's time for Ted  [Music]  Vinci Einstein Picasso Tesla these would  have been better names for the Teenage  Mutant Ninja Turtles that's my opinion  eight ounce glass and you put eight  ounces of water in it that glass is  filled to the rim with water if they're  lime in the coconut you drink it all up  except in this case the lime is  nanotechnology the coconut is personal  apps and you drink it all up and you get  the end of America you're not sir  well I'm not saying you're not a good  time just weird if you're not smiling  but you're saying having a good time you  maybe should tell your face  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]